bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat c'était l'événement de
l'actualité sénatoriales aujourd'hui à
midi le président du sénat gérard
larcher ainsi que les représentants des
différentes commissions présenter la
feuille de route du sénat pour la
fameuse coque 21 la conférence paris
climat 2015 evènement déplacement
rendez-vous le sénat entend être en
première ligne sur la coop 21 parce
qu'il aura évidemment avec l'assemblée
nationale la charge de rendre concret au
niveau national les accords qui pourront
être obtenus lors de cette fameuse
conférence
dans ce contexte je vous propose
aujourd'hui de revoir l'audition de
laurence tubiana menée hier au sénat
l'ambassadrice pour les négociations sur
le réchauffement climatique pour la coop
21 étaient reçus hier par deux
commissions celle des affaires
étrangères et celle du développement
durable pour elle il n'est pas question
que la coop 21 aboutissent à un fonds de
l'accord il faut qu'elle marque un
véritable tournant avec un objectif
ambitieux et chiffrés pour limiter le
réchauffement climatique
on découvre tout de suite cette audition
nous sommes très heureux d'accueillir
aujourd'hui madame tubes y en a qui est
ambassadrice chargée des négociations
sur le changement climatique et la
représentante spéciale pour la
conférence marie climat 2000 cav
sadristes nous sommes très heureux de
vous accueillir un petit peu moins de
200 jours de cette conférence sont très
heureux parce que nous savons que nul
mieux que vous ne peut nous faire le
point sur l'état de préparation de cette
conférence au combien importante et sur
ses chances de succès quelques mots pour
vous dire que
le sénat est très mobilisé sur la
préparation de cette conférence
parce que nous sommes bien conscients
que c'est d'une conférence qui est
importante bien sûr pour la france
puisque c'est la france qui accueille
cette conférence mais elle est surtout
importante pour la planète et plus
encore pour l'humanité puisque comme le
dit souvent nicolas hulot c'est pas la
planète qui est en cause c'est
l'humanité nous mesurerons déjà un
certain nombre d'effets des dérèglements
climatiques y compris dans des pays
comme comme le nôtre avec la montée des
océans avec des phénomènes d'érosion des
côtes avec des événements climatiques
extrêmes de plus en plus fréquents nous
irons d'ailleurs dans pas très longtemps
sur la côte bordelaise voir les effets
de l'érosion des côtes dans cette dans
cette région et donc c'est pour cela que
le sénat est très mobilisé gérard
larcher présentera demain à la presse
les actions que le sénat entend mener
dans les semaines qui viennent et qu'il
a commencé à mener puisque nous avons eu
la semaine dernière un très intéressant
colloque sur les religions et le
réchauffement climatique qui était
extrêmement intéressant nous recevons
ici chaque fois qu'il y à des
parlementaires étrangers qui sont en
france nous les recevons pour faire le
point avec eux et pour essayer quand
c'est nécessaire de les sensibiliser
nous avons au cours de la semaine passée
reçu des parlementaires canadiens nous
avions hier des staffeurs américains
avec lesquels nous avons eu des échanges
très intéressants et bien sûr nous
participons à la mobilisation des
territoires puisque le sénat vous le
savez la chambre qui représente les
territoires et que les territoires sont
ont un rôle aussi important en terme de
de maîtrise des émissions des gaz à
effet de serre et puis je dois dire un
mot sur la préparation de la journée de
lui paie la journée de l'union
interparlementaire qui aura lieu au
sénat le 6 décembre et qui réunira des
parlementaires des différents états
comme ce fut le cas à lima
et nous allons au cours de cette réunion
présenter une résolution j'ai été nommé
rapporteur de cette résolution lors de
l'assemblée jean-louis paix et nous
aimerions vraiment que cette déclaration
qui sera celle des parlementaires et des
parlementaires des parlements pardon
puisse figurer dans les actes philo de
la conférence je le dis parce que c'est
vrai on l'a ressenti à lima pour ce
qu'ils étaient et certains
parlementaires l'on reçoit aussi dans
d'autres circonstances les parlements
les parlementaires ont trop souvent le
sentiment d'être un peu à l'écart de ces
grandes négociations
je sais que c'est pas votre volonté
puisque vous m'avez déjà dû vous leur
direz peut-être aujourd'hui que c'est
important que les parlementaires se
mobilise auprès de leurs homologues
d'autres pays pour les sensibiliser pour
que les parlements respectifs des
différents pays puissent eux mêmes quand
c'est nécessaire
faire pression sur les gouvernements jeu
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui au moment où
on se parle il n'y a que cudi
contributions qui ont été fournis pour
la conférence de décembre alors que
normalement elle devait tout être
fournis pour la fin de la fin du mois de
mars
alors je voudrais que vous nous indiquez
un ambassadrice si à votre avis on a
encore aujourd'hui des chances sérieuses
d'arriver à un véritable accord à paris
c'est à dire un accord contraignant et
universel nous avons le sentiment comme
je le disais qu'il ya pas un
enthousiasme débordant puisque j'ai
indiqué qu'il n'y avait que 10
contribution qui avait été fourni est ce
que vous disiez il n'y a pas très
longtemps qu'une accélération du
processus était nécessaire est ce
qu'elle peut est ce qu'elle peut venir
je crois qu'il ya une une session de
négociations à beaune la semaine
prochaine qu'est ce qu'on peut en
attendre
et puis nicolas hulot que nous avons
reçu il ya quelques semaines nous a
parlé de d'une course contre la montre
alors où en est on dans cette dans cette
course
et puis comme je le disais tout à
l'heure on aimerait également que vous
puissiez nous indiquer en cours à nous
parlementaires nous pouvons être utiles
nous pouvons encore être utile et
notamment
auprès de quel pays faut-il que nous
entrions notre action pour faire en
sorte de contribuer modestement mais de
contribuer quand même à la réussite de
cette conférence merci à hervé madame
l'ambassadrice quelques mots rapides
pour vous souhaiter au nom de la
commission des affaires étrangères et
notre président jean pierre raffarin qui
est malheureusement retenu en séance
publique
vous souhaitez de notre côté la
bienvenue et vous remercier d'avoir
accepté cette rencontre car nous savons
que votre agenda est particulièrement
chargé et votre implication dans ce
dossier est évidemment très important
effectivement le calendrier parce nous
approchons de cette date fatidique
et comme notre collègue le président
n'aurait vous l'a dit le sénat a pris
l'initiative de s'impliquer au travers
de ses différentes délégations de ses
différentes compétences pour prendre
toute sa part dans la préparation de
cette conférence internationale qui
suscite beaucoup d'espoirs
perrin qui malheureusement n'est pas là
mais aussi par notre collègue et il a
échoué à qui j'aurais l'occasion de
donner la parole tout à l'heure après
votre contribution et qui se focalise
notamment sur les conséquences
géopolitiques de la montée des eaux et
sur un sujet aussi tout à fait
passionnant dont on parle beaucoup ces
temps ci dure est la situation dans
l'arctique qui est un continent que nous
connaissons avec nous fréquentons - mais
qui pose aussi beaucoup de questions
pour l'avenir
hervé maurey rappelait la communication
de nicolas hulot qui était une
communication un peu contrastée dans
lequel il nous faisait part de sa
crainte ou en tous les cas de fin d'un
certain nombre d'éléments de
satisfaction mais nous faisait part
aussi de ses craintes et notamment de
l'insuffisance du nombre des premières
contributions nationales qui devaient
été déposé avant je crois la fin mars et
qu'il ne sont toujours pas est ce que c
est un retard administratif ou bien est
ce que c'est vous donner une
signification
à ces retards est ce qu'il ya des pays
avec lequel les choses vont mieux et
d'autres moins bien
et puis surtout donc comment peut-on
mobiliser la société civile au niveau
mondial afin qu'un accord ne reste pas
lettre morte parce qu'il est toujours
facile de signer des accords
internationaux
encore faut-il que tous ces objectifs
soient partagées par nos populations et
que celle ci accepte parfois de faire
des sacrifices auxquels elles n'ont
point à l'habitude
je voudrais au passage rappelé que vous
posez le conseil d'administration de l'
agence française de développement et
qu'à ce titre votre expérience dans ce
domaine-là
la fréquentation des pays en voie de
développement et les projets que l'afd
mène dans ces pays fait de vous une
interlocutrice tout à fait privilégié
par rapport à ces pays
donc moi j'aimerais beaucoup pour avoir
été administrateur de l'afd avant mon
collègue henri de raincourt qui m'a
remplacé
j'aimerais beaucoup que vous puissiez
nous dire comment cette préparation de
la conférence effectué dans ces pays qui
ont des logiques et des problématiques
qui sont parfois sensiblement différents
des nôtres même s'ils sont souvent aussi
les pays qui supportent le plus les
conséquences de ces des règles de ces
dérèglements climatiques
voilà quelques perspectives qui seront
certainement nourri par le jeu des
questions de nos pôles est encore une
fois nous vous remercions parce que nous
mesurons l'immensité de la tâche qui
vous incombent et votre engagement
personnel entier pour que au nom de la
france cette conférence soit un succès
donc sur l'ensemble de ces enjeux de
cette négociation
quel bilan peut-on faire au jour
d'aujourd'hui
voilà quelques thématiques qui je crois
nous rirons cette rencontre donc ils
vont vous permettre pendant une
quinzaine de minutes si vous le voulez
bien de nous présenter une synthèse et
puis après les rapporteurs prendront la
parole et bien sûr nos collègues auront
la liberté de vous poser toutes les
questions dans le temps que vous nous
consacrer je vous remercie madame
l'ambassadrice vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup de cette invitation
c'est toujours un moment important
devant un groupe comme le vôtre de
prendre un peu de recul par raport j'ai
toujours l'impression d'être un
garagiste dans avec les mains dans le
cambouis et de prendre un peu de recul
se demander où on en est effectivement
un peu moins de 100 jours avant avant la
l'étape finale si je puis dire
vous avez déjà l'un et l'autre posé
beaucoup de questions auxquelles je vais
essayer de répondre et peut-être en
recadrant un peu et je le fais beaucoup
d'autant plus que laurent fabius n'a pas
pu venir
devant vous expliquer la vision globale
de ce qu'on attend pour paris je vais
peut-être partir de là du point
d'arrivée pour essayer de revenir nous
en sommes essayer de tracer le chemin
déjà parcouru et de chemin qui reste à
parcourir
et ce faisant répondre déjà à me
semble-t-il à quelques interrogations
vous avez sauvé alors vous l'avez sans
doute entendu à la fois d'une manière ou
d'une autre de mini des affaires
étrangères et du président de la
république par la président de la
république
l'idée qu' on cherche à paris en
tournant non pas seulement un compromis
de plus sur une longue route de
négociations qui durent depuis 1992 jeu
j'aime à dire toutefois que même si
cette période de négociation vous paraît
longue
les négociations sur la libéralisation
du commerce ont commencé en 1948
on peut estimer qu'elle était très
largement achevée il ya encore beaucoup
de secteurs sur lequel il ya du travail
en 1994 sur un sujet beaucoup plus
simple que celui du crime a donc 92 a
aujourd'hui ça paraît long mais on est
c'est quand même moins long que ce qu'on
a déjà fait ce qu'on avait investi dans
le passé sur le commerce et c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué juste pour se
donner un peu la difficulté d'accorder
ce qui au fond une évolution profonde
non seulement des politiques publiques
nationales mais aussi des modèles de
développement et c'est pour ça qu'on
cherche à paris à faire comprendre faire
sentir le fait qu' on est dans un
tournant que on faut que ce qu'on
cherche c'est à dire une économie très
sobre en carbone à terme très peu
fondée sur les ressources fossiles
notamment le charbon le pétrole ou le
gaz est on capable en tout cas n'est pas
aujourd'hui le cas de neutraliser ses
émissions de carbone dans l'atmosphère
et que donc on cherche à offert
converger des anticipations non
seulement des gouvernements et sont
évidemment très divers mais aussi d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs en particulier
les acteurs économiques mais aussi les
collectivités locales qui ont pris un
rôle très important dans cette
discussion sur le climat depuis bien des
années
faire converger 7 ses anticipations pour
partager au fond à la fois l'objectif
général vraiment faire changer les
modèles de développement pour qu'on
puisse rester sous la barre de
l'augmentation de température moyenne de
2 degrés par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle il est du coup changé
profondément toute une série d'éléments
du développement économique
d'aujourd'hui sans pour autant renoncer
à ce développement
sans renoncer à la croissance économique
mais au fond des couples est
profondément les la consommation des
ressources fossiles
d'une certaine manière aussi un peu la
consommation d'énergie même si on peut
de plus en plus produire de l'énergie
propre par rapport au climat et la
croissance économique
donc cette convergence des anticipations
c'est au fond le jeu résultat qu'on
cherche à paris le 12 décembre on
aimerait voir dans les titres des
journaux ça s'exprime ration pas comme
ça de façon plus concrète
cette économie sobre en carbone apparaît
inévitable c'est ce qui va se passer
c'est ce que qui est souhaitable et
c'est ce qu'au fond tous les acteurs
présents financiers économiques
industriels
gouvernements ou autorités locales
pensent que c'est ce qu'il faut faire et
c'est ce qui va arriver et donc on
cherche ça et pour chercher ça cette
convergence des anticipations parce que
il ya une bonne partie comme vous le
disiez c'est la mise en oeuvre l'accord
c'est une chose mais surtout c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe
et qu'est ce qui se passe c'est aussi ça
dépend de la conviction notamment des
acteurs économiques que c'est les
marchés nouveaux que si les solutions
technologiques sont à portée de main ou
quand on voit comment les développer et
c'est une conviction mutuelle des
pouvoirs publics et des acteurs privés
pour qu on aille dans ce chemin c'est
pour ça que l'on présente là le résultat
de paris en quatre volets l'accord
lui-même pour lequel la france a reçu un
mandat en acceptant de temps candidate
pour être l'hôte de la force
la coop 21 les contributions nationales
qui sont puisque nous sommes dans un
système qui est aujourd'hui parle on
appelle par le bas c'est à dire que
c'est des pistes d action d engagement
volontaire des pays sur cette réduction
des émissions est aussi aussi dans
d'autres domaines
donc ça c'est le deuxième volet du
résultat de paris les la mobilisation
des finances et donc la modification au
fond des réponses que le système
financier offre aujourd'hui qu'ils aient
besoin de l'investissement
pourquoi ce système financier dans les
finances publiques que les finances
privées répondre à ce défi de la
transition énergétique économique dans
le monde vers ce monde bas carbone et
enfin les engagements des acteurs non
gouvernementaux car encore une fois il
faut construire cet effet de croyance il
faut montrer qu'il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui pensent
que cette économie sobre en carbone
c'est l'avenir et qui investissent qui
pensent que l'économie fondée sur les
ressources fossiles
elle est risquée du point de vue
économique elle est aussi risqué lorsque
l elle a des conséquences en matière
d'impact de et qui y compris sur les
activités économiques du changement
climatique
c'est aussi le fait de vouloir montrer
que beaucoup d'autorités locales dont
dépendent beaucoup de décisions qui ont
un impact sur le climat notamment en
matière de planification
en n2 politique de transport de enfin la
liste de ce que font les autorités
locales qu'elle aussi elle voit dans ces
villes durables danser dans ses plans de
réduction d'émissions ou d'adaptation au
changement climatique l'avenir de leur
collectivité et donc on voudrait qu'à
paris l'alliance de l'action pour le
climat l'eau le slogan de la coop 21c
unis dans l'action pour le climat et
qu'on m'a va matérialiser sur l'idée
d'un concept d'alliance de paris pour le
climat et cette alliance à représente à
la fois le travail juridique qu'on doit
faire l'accord c'est décision nationale
souveraine de s'engager dans ce modèle
de développement et le la réponse du
système financier et enfin donc les
engagements des acteurs non
gouvernementaux et donc en partie qu en
pratique on a forcément du coup
puisqu'on veut c4 résultat une
diplomatie et le bénin à 360° parce que
l'on doit à la fois travailler avec les
gouvernements à différents niveaux chefs
d'état ministres négociateurs on doit
travailler je dirais non pas avec ceux
qui négocient seulement mais ceux qui
sont dans les pays en train de
construire les politiques énergétiques
des différents pays
enfin on doit aussi travailler avec le
des acteurs du système financier et
enfin aussi déployer développer un site
et ses acteurs non gouvernementaux qui
veulent s'engager à le faire de façon
compréhensible vérifiables aussi pour
que cela donne confiance à tout le monde
donc on a une diplomatie sur tous ces
éléments on est évidemment puissamment
aidé par un réseau diplomatique qui
reste exceptionnel l'échelle mondiale
une mobilisation sans précédent de ce
réseau diplomatique
je crois que un grand étonnement de mes
collègues négociateur il n'avait jamais
vu avant un ambassadeur de france là il
le rencontre en général tous les mois et
demi
parfois ils trouvent que c'est même
beaucoup quoi et donc on a dans les
ambassades dans chaque poste
une mobilisation en direction des
négociateurs et les ministres qui
négocie des collectivités locales des
industries est donc mobilisation 360
degrés
et peut-être maintenant en venir ou
est-ce qu'on en est alors vous vous
m'avez tendu une perche en disant
pourquoi ce qu'on en est loin puisqu'on
a que 10 contribution 37 ans comptant
évidemment les pays de l'union
alors pourquoi ça ne l'inquiète pas
outre mesure le 31 mars qu'était la date
une date de pour les pays qui peuvent le
faire fixer à lima donc s'il n'était pas
une date obligatoire la date butoir elle
est au moins d'octobre
l'exercice est très compliqué jean
discuté hier avec la secrétaire
exécutive de la commission économique
pour l'amérique latine continent qui
s'est beaucoup mobilisée pour le climat
et dont les pays peine à rédiger leur
contribution en alicia barcena me disais
c'est une prise de conscience crédit
très très importante entre dire qu'on
veut faire quelque chose pour le climat
et commencer à se dire en 2025 en 2030
comment je vais réduire les émissions
comment je vais le faire dans le secteur
de l'énergie dans le secteur des
transports dans le secteur dans le
secteur industriel est ce que j'utilise
des instruments politiques fiscales
est-ce que je me fixe un objectif de
réduction absolue des émissions
tout ça est quelque chose pour beaucoup
de pays qui étaient pas fait qu'il
n'avait jamais été fait et il est normal
et quand je vois un peu la nature de la
préparation de la contribution chinoise
qui va être très détaillé c'est aussi
comme ici quand on a les amendements à
la loi transition énergétique c de même
nature
même si la portée du regard va pas tout
à fait aussi loin mais enfin 2025 ou
2030 c'est très c'est un chaînon 1 comme
horizon air etc des batailles politiques
dans chaque pays qui sont extrêmement
fortes
il ya évidemment les protestations des
industriels s'ils pensent que ça va
gêner leur développement ce qui les
agriculteurs ou ou des forestiers qui
ont peur que ça enfin vous imaginez tous
les débats et partout il y à des débats
intenses à la fois la prise de
conscience des gouvernements que il
s'agit plus d'un espèce de chose un peu
abstraite que c'est très concret ça va
se traduire ça doit se traduire dans la
politique domestique et que c'est en
même temps
très très compliqué donc c'est normal
que ça prenne du temps c'est des
arbitrages complexe financier sur le au
fond le taux de croissance espéré sur
comment on va faire enfin et donc au
contraire moi je ne suis pas pessimiste
sur l'engagement des pays à présenter
des contributions je crois qu'on aura
beaucoup beaucoup peut-être pas 195
contribution à paris mais on aura très
largement les 99.99 recouvrant les
émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre qui seront comprises dans ces
contributions et une bonne partie vont
arriver dans les semaines qui viennent
les autres pendant l'été je crois qu'en
octobre on aura en tout cas de quoi voir
où nous en sommes alors sûrement nicolas
hulot a partagé son ses inquiétudes sur
la nature de ces contributions pour et
ce pour ce qu'on en sait elles ne
pourront pas en plus qu'à l'horizon 2025
ou 2030 répondre à la question est ce
qu'on est sur la bonne trajectoire pour
respecter l'objectif collectif qu'on
s'est donné qui sera réaffirmée à paris
celui de ne pas dépasser cette
augmentation des 2 degrés par rapport à
l'ère préindustrielle c'est vrai ces
contributions soient encore plus
ambitieuse que précédemment
bien plus ambitieuse que précédemment
mais sans doute insuffisante et c'est
donc tout le tout l'enjeu de l'accord de
paris de prévoir comment on rattrape
progressivement cette trajectoire qui
est compatible avec 2 degrés qui est
très c'est une trajectoire sévères en
matière d'émissions mondiales il faut
pas oublier que c'est au moins 50% de
réduction des émissions mondiales par
rapport à 90 en 2050 ou même par rapport
à 2000 et où ce qui est à peu près
équivalent
c'est donc
une grande transformation ça veut dire
que les pays
beaucoup de pays en développement
commencent à réduire leurs émissions de
façon absolue évidemment c'est ce que la
chine a accepté en principe mais encore
faut-il qu'elles que ça sera
suffisamment tôt et suffisamment fortes
à dire que la descente ensuite des
émissions soient significatives
donc on a plein d'enjeux qui explique à
la fois la difficulté de venir avec des
propositions concrètes rapidement et en
même temps le sentiment que j'ai que
tous veulent le faire et veulent le
faire le plus sérieusement possible
alors que ce point de vue voilà où on en
est je pense que on aura un meilleur
tableau déjà d'ici quelques semaines
certainement donc entre le 1er et le 15
ou le 20 juin et une nouvelle vague qui
vont arriver dans le courant de l'été
dans le courant du mois d'août où le
début du mois de septembre
alors où est ce qu'on en est sûre les
grands points de la négociation doit
être un petit peu de deux technologies
de la négociation comment est ce qu'on
fait vous savez qu être président de la
conférence des parties
en principe nous prenons cette résidence
formellement le premier le 30 novembre
jusque là on travaille dans les
coulisses on le fait avec la présidence
péruvienne qui elle est officiellement
présidente jusqu'en jusqu'au 30 novembre
et donc on le fait à la pour beaucoup de
raisons d'abord pour pouvoir travailler
plutôt ce qu'on a commencé à faire dès
le mois de février et ensuite pour
s'associer à un pays en développement
écoutée respectée par part disons les
autres pays en développement et cela
nous permet de ne pas au fond ne pas
être vu simplement comme grands pays
européens qui voudraient éventuellement
imposer ses vues donc on sent on essaie
de ceux de cette façon de se prémunir
contre le syndrome qui a très largement
accepté la présidence danoise à
copenhague
donc l'association étroite avec le pérou
fait partie à mon sens des chances de
succès qu'on accumule pour paris du
capital politique on essaie de craie
pour paris la deuxième le deuxième chose
qu'on fait aussi du point de vue de la
technologie des négociations outre le
fait de mobiliser notre réseau c
d'organiser des réunions informelles de
négociations on essaye de faire
rapprocher les points de vue on l'a fait
à lima en mars à paris en mai on va
encore continuer en juillet et en
septembre et là à des différents niveaux
au niveau des chefs de négociation des
négociateurs ou des ambassadeurs ou au
niveau des ministres donc on a eu un
moment important là dix jours maintenant
je confonds un peu les dates je dois
voyager trop mais à petersberg à berlin
où la chancelière merkel et président
hollande comme vous l'avez vu en ont
conclu les travaux de ce dialogue de
petersberg où on a vu à la fois que les
choses commençaient à devenir sérieuses
c'est à dire il y as et c'est évident
une volonté d'aboutir à paris il y
encore une fois vraiment le souhait d'y
arriver est de montrer par ses
contributions nationales l'attachement à
cet accord collectif et donc de lui
donner ce caractère universel mais
maintenant nous rentrons dans la phase
difficile où chacun évidemment ferme un
peu les positions parce que on doit
discuter des choses difficiles lesquels
sont elles ces choses difficiles elles
sont d'abord ces grands points
politiques non résolus au fond ils sont
au nombre de 4 4 ou 5 le premier c'est
cet objectif de 2 degrés est ce qu'on
arrive à à lui donner un peu de chair un
peu de concret 2° qu'est ce que ça veut
dire alors essayez 1 en 2010 en 2009 d'y
arriver
2° était un proxy comme on dit une
approximation pour ne pas avoir un
chiffre de réduction absolue des
émissions mondiales à l'échelle 2050 à
l'horizon 2050 ou bien pour ne pas
traduire ça en terme de concentration
des émissions dans un chiffre de
concentration des émissions dont 2
degrés en se référant scénarios du giec
était une manière de contourner
l'obstacle alors on va garder cet
objectif
la labellisation formel c'est essayer de
contenir les températures entre 1.5 et
en dessous de deux degrés c'est la
revendication notamment des petites
villes et des pays africains mais aller
plus loin vers cet objectif vous avez
sans doute entendu dire soit le
président de la république
soit laurent fabius soit d'autre il
faudra essayer de dire on est à zéro
émission net à la fin du siècle où
l'idée encore qu'on doit éventuellement
réduire les émissions la commission
européenne propose le chiffre de - 60 %
des émissions mondiales par rapport à
2010 donc on a plusieurs versions pour
essayer d'indiquer quelque chose de
concret qui pourrait servir de guide
donc pas d'accord là dessus pour
l'instant en grande partie parce que on
a un problème de très simple d'une
équation à qui pourrait être une
équation à une inconnue
2° au fond ça corresponde quand même une
certaine concentration des températures
si on sait que les pays développés sont
prêts à réduire leurs émissions long
tout s'annonçait déjà 2009 de 80 à 95%
d'ici 2050
la seule inconnue qui reste adéquation
c'est la réduction des émissions du côté
des pays en développement et c'est ça
qui fait problème donc difficulté de
donner des chiffres parce que donnait un
chiffre de résultats 450 particules par
million ou un chiffre de réduction des
émissions mondiales par soustraction et
parce qu'on sait ce que les pays
développés se sont engagés à faire était
déjà ambitieux et bien ça donne le reste
du chemin à parcourir pour les autres
émetteurs et notamment évidemment au
premier lieu la chine et l'inde a assez
vite derrière elle donc premier point
difficile on a plusieurs réponses à cela
on essaie de trouver des formules
peut-être pic des émissions le plus tôt
possible
l'idée qu'on pousse idée qui progresse
beaucoup qui est une idée qui vient de
la france de pousser chaque pays a
volontairement décrire son scénario
d'évolution économique compatible avec 2
degrés d'ici 2050 non pas sous une forme
d'engagement solide mais plutôt d'une
vision pour aussi faire rentrer dans les
esprits et puis regardez qu'est ce que
ça suppose comme
transformation problèmes technologiques
etc mais donc c'est sur la table
le deuxième grand sujet c'est évidemment
les finances puisque à la fois on sait à
copenhague en 2009 puis en 2010 plus
formellement engagé du côté des pays
développés à trouver 100 milliards
financés du nord vers le sud de façon
publique et privée le développement
sobres des pays en développement d'ici
2020 qu'on a beaucoup de difficultés
aujourd'hui encore à fournir exactement
qu'est ce qu'on fait déjà et plusieurs
estimations qui sont qui ont été publiés
notamment par la banque mondiale disant
que la financement public est de l'ordre
de 37 millions de 37 milliards par an
aujourd'hui
donc il faut augmenter quand même 7 ses
financements et deuxième question
comment est-ce qu'on reconnaît identifie
le financement privé qui s'investit
aussi dans les objectifs climatiques
dans les pays en développement
tout ça fait partie de la discussion ce
qui est certain c'est que ce qui il faut
obtenir d'ici paris c'est une
compréhension commune de ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui de ce qu'on compte une
trajectoire est semblable d'augmentation
des finances publiques et privées d'ici
2020 et sans doute spécificité de ce
qu'on doit consacrer notamment au sujet
de l'adaptation changement climatique
est un grand sujet et en particulier des
pays les plus pauvres
on a deux troisième grand sujet de débat
qui est la question de kelly à la proue
ce que je disais sur les contributions
une si ces contributions sont
insuffisantes ce qu'elles sont
quelles seront très probablement ce qui
est normal comment est ce qu'on fait
pour les réviser à la hausse comment
est-ce que avant 2030 ou avant 2025 on
instaure un mécanisme de revues
d'augmentation de ces contributions pour
qu'on se mette sur cette fameuse c'est
cette ou ces fameuses trajectoire
compatible avec 2 degrés et là on a tout
un débat très difficile pour instaurer
ces cycles soit de façon mécanique soit
de façon plus flexible et là on a des
difficultés notamment
la chine est résistante à l'idée d'un
accord qu'on verrait régulièrement
3 troisième sujet dit fixe difficile la
vérification et la mesure des progrès
des uns et des autres alors tout le
monde est d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faut un mécanisme de vérification et de
rapportage la nature de cette de cette
obligation le degré d' ingérence dans
les affaires intérieures pour vérifier
que les chiffres sont bien les bons font
évidemment l'objet du débat
et quatrièmement la grande question est
au fond est ce qu on a les mêmes règles
pour tout le monde
ou est-ce que les mêmes obligations pour
tout le monde ou calais la nature et le
degré de la différenciation entre pays
développés et pays en développement sur
ses obligations
quand je veux pas être trop longue donc
je vais m'arrêter bientôt on a donc
devant nous un peu moins de 6 mois les
négociations formelles à la fin la
semaine de sept semaines qui vont
démarrer qui sont alors j'ai beaucoup
dit il faut accélérer le tempo parce que
nous voulons du côté de la présidence
française
à voir dès octobre quand même les
grandes lignes de ce que peut être la
corde on ne pas attendre le moment de
paris pour cela il faut accélérer le
rythme donc aller les messages
d'accélération sont très intentionnelle
ils ont été repris à différents niveaux
d'abord par le président de la
république ensuite par le laurent fabius
et je le relais tant que je peux pour
dire il faut qu'on octobre on sache où
est ce qu'on va qu'on est les grands
éléments du paquet du paquet politique a
finalisé à paris il y aura un moment
important du g7 de juin parce que la
chancelière merkel veut faire de ce g7
se présidence allemande un important
moment pour le climat notamment du point
de vue financier il y aura d'autres
moments importants en parallèle de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
où françois hollande et ban ki moon le
secrétaire général vont réunir un
certain nombre de chefs d'état pour
donner l'impulsion finale et nous aurons
avant le g20 une grande réunion un lima
en octobre pour traiter du sujet
financier qui cela avant la coop de
décembre il ya un agenda en parallèle
que sur lequel je voudrais pas revenir
parce que sinon ce serait trop long mais
on suit donc une série à la fois de
conférences de mobilisation pour
mobiliser les entreprises
vous l'avez vu la semaine dernière à
paris il y aura d'autres étapes avant
paris de cette mobilisation des
entreprises soit sur les engagements
individuels soient les engagements des
feuilles de route sectorielle soit sur
les engagements en matière d'innovation
technologique
même chose du côté des autorités locales
même chose du côté des acteurs
financiers
donc ce que vous avez vu à paris il va
se reproduire pour d'autres acteurs à
lyon en juillet ensuite en septembre à
new york en octobre à lima comme je le
disais et sans doute avec d'autres
points de rendez vous en octobre à
genève ou à paris sont aussi partie de
ceux de ses autres agendas du
négociations qu'on poursuit pour que
lier un peu à la fois un momentum
politiques et beaucoup de beaucoup de
soutien
beaucoup de courage donné au
gouvernement pour s'engager davantage
je vous propose qu'à ce stade je m'en
tienne la queue alors je n'ai pas
répondu
enfin je pourrais pas répondre à toutes
vos questions en détail mais je le ferai
peut-être plus t'as plus petit peu par p
type sur la situation particulière
notamment des pays africains qui sont à
la fois très engagé plus engagés
qu'auparavant plus coordonnée
qu'auparavant d'ailleurs qui préparent
des contributions il ya eu des
stratégies différentes mais la plupart
des pays africains sont engagés dans une
préparation je pense au sénégal à
l'ethiopie au kenya bien sûr à l'afrique
du sud mais aussi un la république
centrafricaine a bien d'autres au
mozambique en fin donc on va les voir
arriver au courant de l'été la
préoccupation pour eux c'est moi la
réduction des émissions que l'adaptation
aux changements climatiques mais aussi
de s'engager du point de vue notamment
des sources d'énergie vers les énergies
propres et non pas de faire le moins
possible le passage par le charbon
où le pétrole de faire tant que faire se
peut des programmes d'efficacité
énergétique suffisamment tôt pour me
réduire le poids du coût de l'énergie
dans leur croissance économique pour
notamment pour ceux qui ont évidemment
qui n'ont pas de ressources minières ou
pétrolières propre donc une mobilisation
assez grande des pays africains à une
attente très grande des pays africains
sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique et la réponse que les pays
développés notamment du point de vue
financier feront un grand sujet
agricoles forêts aussi qu'il faut pas
oublier pour ce pays qui est très
important est ce qu'on peut avoir une
agriculture adaptée aux changements
climatiques
on va y avoir moins de précipitation
dans beaucoup de zones trop de
précipitation dans d'autres et que cette
agriculture puisse se faire suffisamment
vivre les populations locales pour que
l'on n'ait pas besoin de continuer cette
déforestation qui est aussi un grand
problème dans beaucoup de zones donc
voila un petit peu mon lancement de
balle
et puis évidemment je suis toute ouïe
sur vos questions quant à donner la
parole à jean bignon qui est le
président du groupe de travail sur les
négociations climatiques qui peut et
ensuite je suis rapporteur de la
commission des affaires étrangères ont
aussi là le souhait légitime
d'intervenir et après d'autres
d'autres membres des deux commissions
qui ont pendant intention de s'exprimer
merci monsieur plaisir merci madame
l'ambassadrice pour vous pour vos propos
que j'ai trouvé rassurant parce que
j'avais été un peu inquiet en lisant
dans la presse récemment que vous aviez
l'air plus pessimiste que vous l'avez
été aujourd'hui vous avez été très
positifs et c'est vrai que c'est
encourageant quand on mène une
négociation aussi difficile il ya
probablement des jours avec et des jours
sans et peut-être le jour où vous avez
interrogé
vous n'aviez pas le en train que vous
avez la plupart du temps
ah ça peut être tactique aussi alors moi
j'ai trois questions un peu de technique
au fond parce que vous avez dit vous
avez déjà rappelé beaucoup de choses
vous nous avez parlé du dialogue de
petersberg qui n'est pas une expression
qu'on voit souvent dans la négociation
internationale moi je sais que c'est une
négociation qui fait c'est une enceinte
qui a été menée créé par les allemands
en 2010 donc après l'échec de de
copenhague pour nous le dialogue j'ai vu
qu'il y avait une 35 pays qui
participaient mais qu'elle est qu'est-ce
qui différencie
petersburgh du reste de la la négo à
part le pouvoir d' influence de la
chancelière
c'est une première question deuxième
question chez j'ai vu que le le prince
albert de monaco c'était avait sollicité
alors ça va paraître très bizarre ce que
je vais dire mais que quinquin absent
des négociations ils soient réintégrés
c'est l'océan vous avez présidé l'iddri
très longtemps avec beaucoup de
détermination et vous avez mis l'océan
sur le devant de la scène a bien pu avec
beaucoup de détermination ce qui nous
vaut probablement aujourd'hui d'avoir à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
de septembre le renégociation d'un bout
de mon ego b qui manquait au grand large
le prince s'inquiètent de ne pas voir
l'océan dans la négociation c'est vrai
qu'on est passé sur réduction des gaz à
effet de serre et les réductions de gaz
à effet de serre on les imagine comme
une donnée terrestre et dans il ya toute
une partie de l'opinion publique
notamment qui se retrouvent dans la
plateforme océan et climat qui était un
peu triste de ne pas voir la prise en
compte de l'océan comme un formidable
puits de carbone et comme un formidable
émetteurs de l'oxygène jeu participé
hier matin encore et que madame
madame guèye gaye qui est une chercheuse
bien connu du crs que vous connaissez
bien
qui regrette ça aussi donc peut-être
pourriez nous donner un mot
d'explication encore une fois que je ne
juge pas il ya un parti pris qui a été
donnée mais pourquoi ne pas se donner la
chance de mettre l'océan dans la dans la
partie et puis peut-être un point encore
rapide
j'ai entendu dire qu'il ya des gens qui
étaient qui joue un rôle enfin je les
cités parce qu'on s'était les chinois en
particulier qui joue un peu derrière le
rideau
c'est à dire qu'ils ont une stratégie
qui consiste à dire on est un pays
émergent c'est très difficile pour nous
et c est en même temps derrière le
rideau qui est la traduction de
l'expression anglaise
ils jouent un rôle très puissant en
matière de réflexion industrielles
nouvelles technologies innovations sans
sens là sans la dévoiler iter qui jouent
aux pauvres devant et derrière ils se se
construise un avenir dont je me réjouis
d'ailleurs pour le peuple chinois et
pour le monde entier
mais qui est un peu ambiguë par rapport
au rôle qu'ils prétendent jouer sur le
devant de la scène
est ce qu'on parle de ça est ce que ça
fait partie du du d'un sujet dans l'est
dans les négociations voilà très
rapidement trois points d'ender
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
étrangères
merci monsieur le président madame là
l'ambassadrice vous remercier là pour le
coup je suis plutôt de nature
extrêmement optimiste et là en revanche
je le serai peut-être un peu moins
je suis effectivement rapporteur de la
com de
du rapport de la commission des affaires
étrangères sur le dérèglement climatique
et précisément sur l'impact géopolitique
nous avons eu un certain nombre
d'auditions depuis le depuis quelques
temps et un certain nombre de
scientifiques qui en est sont plutôt si
je puis dire à la alarmiste non pas sur
le seuil de deux grecs dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure mais plutôt sur une
échelle de 4 degrés celsius voire même
certains sont déjà sur des logiques de 4
à 6 degrés donc je je note avec intérêt
que les négociations porte simplement
sur une limitation à ne pas dépasser les
2 degrés donc quid de ce delta qui est
pas du tout une une hypothèse mais une
réalité qui a été développé à plusieurs
reprises par en tout cas dans l'ensemble
des auditions qu'on a pu avoir ça c'est
ma première remarque et j'aurai trois
questions est ce que vous pensez
si on reprend l'accord conclu entre les
etats-unis et la chine ont septembre ou
octobre dernier qui à eux deux
représentent à peu près 42 % du total
des gaz à elle des départs dans des
émissions de co2 est ce que vous
considérez que cet accord est plutôt une
opportunité plutôt un bon signe ou au
contraire est-ce que c'est typiquement
le genre d'accord qui peut mettre à mal
les négociations pour la coop 21 ma
seconde question un très justement sur
l'organisation vous avez dit à juste
titre qui convenait de mobiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs de notre société
particulièrement les entreprises
aujourd'hui nous savons à peu près que
disent les dix plus grandes entreprises
mondiales sur les 10 plus grandes parts
dont huit d'entre elles ont une activité
directement liés aux activités fossiles
comment vous arrivez à les mobiliser
justement puisque précisément l'objectif
de la cap 21 à l'encontre de leur
business man puisque fondamentalement
leur structure économique et simplement
centrée sur les énergies fossiles et
encore une fois sur ces digues plus
grandes entreprises force est de
rappeler qu'il n'ya pas de banque
ça c'est ma deuxième question sur ma
troisième question en ce qui concerne le
le fond vert et éventuellement les aides
dédiées à un certain pays certain nombre
de pays en développement
il ya une ambiguïté sur la terminologie
puisque du en fonction du groupe auquel
on appartient on peut lui donner une
qualification juridique alors
soit l'aide est considéré par les
bailleurs de fonds comme étant une aide
et donc les bailleurs de fonds ont un
droit de regard sur la manière dont les
fonds sont utilisés soit si on est du
côté entre guillemets des pays qui se
considère comme étant victime de la
surconsommation du nord pour la faire
schématique soit cette aide est
considérée comme étant une dette de
cette pollution des pays développés et
dans ce cas ils n'ont pas le droit fin
il n'y a pas de raison que permettent et
autorise un droit de regard est ce que
cette notion est définitivement est-ce
que c'est des sujets sur lesquels vous
êtes travailler afin justement d'éviter
des interprétations qui demain seront
sujets à discussion et à blocage ou en
tout cas qui ne permettront pas des
avancées significatives pour lutter
justement contre le lait les commandes
hier les gaz à effet de serre et enfin
j'avais dit 3 excusez moi j'avais une
quatrième question je finirai là dessus
un sujet qui me qui me paraît
extrêmement important contenu donc et je
reviendrai sur mon introduction sur mon
propos plutôt sur un schéma à 4° non pas
à deux donc avec comme conséquence
directe des déplacements de populations
extrêmement important nous avons eu un
certain nombre d'auditions sur lequel
nous avons posé la question de savoir si
la france se soucier à vérifier
placez l'on appellera comme on veut mais
simplement pour proposer l'idée soit de
déplacés environnementaux soient de
réfugiés environnementaux soient de
réfugiés climatiques
il nous apparaît en tout cas clairement
à l'issue des différentes auditions que
nous avons pu avoir que la france n'a
pas tranché ce sujet et en ce qui me
concerne je m'excuse d'ailleurs pour mon
collègue cédric perrin qui avait une
contrainte
en ce qui nous concerne il nous semble
en tout cas qu'il est peut être
important pour la france qu'elle se
saisisse du ce de ce sujet puisque les
déplacés climatiques ou la définition
qu'on voudra bien en données sont pas
une lubie mais quelque chose qui enfin
un phénomène qui arrivera est ce que la
france n'a pas intérêt à anticiper
aujourd'hui nous sommes encore un pays
influent dans 20 ou 30 ans ça sera
peut-être pas le cas est-ce qu'on n'a
pas encore intérêt à influer justement
aujourd'hui apporter ce sujet parce
qu'en tout cas ce qui est ressorti de
nos différentes auditions c'est que
c'est un sujet qu'on évite pour dérision
en tout cas de politique intérieure
qu'on peut comprendre mais ce n'est pas
le débat d'aujourd'hui
je vous remercie j'aurais peut-être
ajouter dans le prolongement de ce qu'a
dit dsk évoqué leila aichi à quel niveau
de dechy fra j'allais dire vous placez
le succès de cette conférence
on vient d'avoir l'expérience en avril
la conférence de l'onu sur les risques
naturels qui s'est soldée je crois vers
le 18 mars par un quasi échec peut y
avait une sympathie déclarations il y
avait aucun objectif chiffré il y avait
aucun financement et aucune sanction
comment dans le rôle qui est le vôtre
tentez-vous d'imposer ou en tous les cas
de faire accepter un certain nombre de
chiffrage précis de telle sorte que là
aussi on évite le danger des conférences
internationales qui se termine par des
belles déclarations mais qui n'ayant pas
d'objectif n'ayant pas de sanction est
l'occasion pour les pays en voie
développement n'ayant pas d'être
financières prévues aboutissent
finalement à pas grand chose très simple
vraiment très sympa je vais prendre un
peu dans l'ordre ce dialogue de
petersberg bas c'est typiquement le la
manière d'essayer de au fond d'eux
d'éclaircir les points politiques que
les négociateurs n'arrive pas à trancher
dans le processus multilatéral habituel
c'est la même chose que ce qu'on fait
lorsqu'on va organiser d informelle au
niveau ministériel ou que les états unis
organisent en invitant au sein du forum
des économies majeures aussi au niveau
des chefs de délégations ou des héros
des ministres on a besoin de ce type
d'enceintes pour un peu vaincre
l'inertie du système multilatéral qui
est compliqué en essayant de dans un
dans des enceintes où on ne négocie pas
mais on essaie de se comprendre on
essaie d'identifier des convergences ou
de bien éclaircir les divergences
d'avancé pour qu'ensuite on traduisent
puisque il faut toujours se souvenir que
les négociations multilatérales ce sont
des négociations de juristes vous pariez
de l'océan et c'est ça et donc dé
négocier un texte juridique vous
connaissez les juristes et de leur
grande rigueur
c'est très compliqué non couvert très
précis donc il faut au moins des monts
ça y est les concepts pour savoir si on
peut trouver la formule est donc d'où
l'intérêt de ces deux séances un plus
politique qui essaie de se dire bon fond
comment on va trouver les 10 les
différents compromis donc c'est
l'utilité
je pense que ç'a bien fonctionné cette
année aussi
c'est un bon tout une bonne
représentation de dison de la diversité
des pays s'est tassée en général
suffisamment divers pour qu'on y
retrouve les différents groupes de
négociation où les différentes
catégories de pays l'a peut-être la
difficulté c'est que les on a besoin
d'atterrir sur des sujets concrets on a
balayé un peu large mais ça a été au
fond la première discussions
ministérielles
que nous avions depuis le début de
l'année donc de ce point de vue elle a
été très importante et la chancelière
avait laissé à la france beaucoup de
place pour donner une autre vision des
choses
donc ça nous a été très utile s'agissant
des océans et le malheur qui veut qu'ils
soient des puits de carbone qui
évidemment des grades énormément
lassitude l'écosystème océanique dans
son entier à cause de ces concentrations
élevées dans l'atmosphère je pense que à
la fois ya beaucoup de pays qui ont
envie que l'on traite des sujets des
océans
il faut trouver la formule et c'est pas
simple les forêts au fond qui a été un
peu le premier écosystème qui a été
touché la question de la désertification
est un peu la même enfin dans des
problèmes très différents mais au fond
les forêts on l'a attaqué des deux côtés
c'était à la fois un puits de carbone
mais qu'on pouvait éventuellement
protégé puisque si on évite la
déforestation
on évite de perdre tout c'est comme
tonnes de carbone stockée accumulé puis
on permet de régénérer aussi cette forêt
et la question de l'océan c'est comment
est-ce qu'on freine cette acidification
comment est ce que justement c'est pas
l'océan qui est la variable d'ajustement
majeure qui va rapidement vers une
détérioration de la faune et de la flore
découvre enfin je ne vous fais pas le
tableau puisque vous le connaissez très
bien donc c'est à la fois très important
de parler des océans et en même temps
par quel biais en attaque ça reste que
c'est au fond la conséquence de nos
actions qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
protéger les océans à scander des choses
qu'on peut faire déjà il ya des choses
assez évidente mais qui sont
l'exploitation des sous du sous sol
on peut essayer de faire moins grave
mais quand même l'enjeu essentiel pour
les océans c2c de réduire les émissions
mondiales
c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à faire donc
ou bien tu accroître les capacités
d'absorption par d'autres fuites carbone
qui sont les sols ces deux problèmes en
grand sujet qui est en train d'émerger
heureusement par l'agriculture
la fertilisation des sols qui
permettrait de justement de soulager un
peu l'absorption des des océans et aussi
par la meilleure gestion des forêts donc
à neuf on tourne autour du sujet océan
parce que le sujet océans pour l'instant
c'est un sujet d' impact du changement
climatique
davantage qu'un sujet de solutions et
donc c'est à la fois un point important
et en même temps si on le mettait
n'importe où ça n'irait ça sert à rien
on parlerait de l'océan pour parler de
l'océan et j'en discute beaucoup avec
mes collègues du monde des océans qui
voudraient bien que le sur ocean
apparaissent partout et en même temps on
n'a pas encore trouvé comment est ce que
on traite cela autrement que en essayant
de se donner peut-être s'est pas encore
mûr mais ça pourrait être peut-être en
passant par les processus scientifique
de se donner des objectifs en matière de
au fonds de 7,2 cette absorption ça
pourrait être en verre d'eau donc on est
quand même en réfléchis y ait eu
quelques papiers je crois qu'on en avait
publié à l'iddri à l'époque de se donner
un peu une vision mais mais je dois dire
que d'ici paris apprend une mention y
aura une mention sur des océans à
plusieurs endroits une solution il ya un
objectif par exemple chiffré pour les
océans je pense que l'on n'en est pas
encore là alors sur sur cette question
chinoise s'est pas vraiment derrière le
rideau
la chine est le premier investisseur en
matière d'énergies renouvelables est
aussi premier investisseur en charbon en
données centrales à charbon cela dit
elle est en train de prendre un virage
considérable puisque alors c'est pas
clair et on va voir si c'est dans la
contribution chinoise sont pas elle se
donne un objectif en matière de
limitation puisse de décroissance de la
consommation de charbon en chine
donc c'est un peu comme le débat fin
très différemment c'est un peu comme le
débat nucléaire renouvelable ici en
france on a le même type de débat en
chine il ya des gens qui disent quand
même on a cette ressource pourquoi
lagache et on sait faire c'est ça qu'a
fait le groupe industrialisation
pourquoi commencer à faire quelque chose
d'autre et d'autres qui disent mais au
contraire bon c'est la pollution locale
enfin on peut trouver vous prenez le
débat aux états unis enfin on a quand
même beaucoup de parallèles
donc je dirais pas que c'est bien que la
chine veut y à la fois faire elle-même
et parier sur l' économie sobre en
carbone c'est absolument vrai il c'est
ça le changement fondamental qu'on a
observée depuis 2010 c'est ce changement
de la vision de la chine sur son
économie en 2009 parlé d' économie sobre
en carbone en chine
c'était une menace aujourd'hui même les
négociateurs chinois disent ce qu'il
nous faut dans l'accord de paris c'est
quelque chose qui crédibilise qui fasse
qu on aille tous vers une économie sobre
en carbone
donc pour eux c'est une priorité il veut
pas y aller tout seul pour des raisons
comme nous on voudrait pas aller tout
seul dans cette direction là aussi pour
des raisons de compétitivité et
d'intégration d'économie mondiale donc
c'est pas de derrière le rideau ce qui
est ce qu'ils veulent pas ce qu'ils
essayent de protéger le plus possible
c'est leur propre rythme leurs propres
décisions et donc ils veulent le moins
d'obligations internationales possible
mais de la direction dans lequel ils
vont à l est pas contestable et
d'ailleurs pas brouiller on le voit à
travers et les décisions qui ont été
prises certainement la préparation du
troisième plan on va avoir quelque chose
d'intéressant y aura la contribution
chinoise probablement mois de juin et et
des éléments très concrets de mise en
oeuvre déjà dans les décisions prises
pour le 13ème plan qui courent donc de
2016 à 2005 cinq ans plus tard donc à de
on aura les mesures assez précise fin
août
donc je pense je le plains du sérieux de
encore une fois dans un débat féroce
parce qu'en chine
tous portent sur quel est le taux de
croissance sur lequel on parie pour les
15 prochaines années ce qui est un sujet
éminemment politique
moi c'est un sujet d'économie c'est un
sujet est ce qu'on dit qu'on va être à
10% par an et que tout repose donc sur
cette course effrénée aux 10% par an où
est-ce qu'on est à cinq ou est ce qu'on
à 6 61 7 et c'est ça qui fait des
scénarios chinois en réalité presque
tous les instituts de recherche chinois
y compris pense que les émissions
mondiales peuvent chinoises peuvent se
réduire à partir de 2025
mais ils ne veulent pas s'engager à ça
parce que s'engager à ça ça voudrait
dire déjà faire à paris taux de
croissance relativement faible pour
l'instant donc le découplage tant qu'on
n'est pas complètement sur le découplage
peut s'affirmer de plus en plus entre
énergie consommation d'énergie est
particulièrement d'énergies fossiles et
pibe la variable d'ajustement c'est le
taux de croissance du pib est donc il
est compréhensible que ça soit un peu
derrière le rideau parce que c'est juste
que c'est un sujet politique
super difficile encore une fois je me
réfère aux débats que prévu beaucoup
participé sur la transition énergétique
dire qu'on divise par deux la
consommation d'énergie française en 2050
ça avait l'air de dire pour sacrifier
l'économie française c'est exactement le
genre de débat encore une fois alors sur
cette question du du 4° que vous avez
posé ma la magie fois que vous imposez
vous constatez que les le les
conclusions de nos collègues
le leap et six aux fins du giec et les
climatologues français que vous avez
sûrement auditionné se fonde quand même
sur des contributions qu'ils sont enfin
c'est le business as usual de maintenant
c'est ça 4° 4 au dessus de quatre jeux
encore une fois il faut voir ce que nous
donne la récolte de ces premières
contributions on sera à ce moment là
encore une fois c'est une trajectoire et
c'est des probabilités
c'est pas des déterminations mécanique
plutôt quelque chose entre 3 et 4 3 3
degrés ou trois degrés et demi je pense
que enfin tout l'objectif de l'accord
c'est de se donner un mécanisme pour
faire que cette trajectoire qui passent
plutôt qu'ils nous donnent plus de 50%
de chances de probabilités d'être
au-dessus de 3 degrés en stabilisé
puisque c'est pas une date précise que
que ceci se passe c'est effectivement de
prévoir ces mécanismes rouen va
accentuer l'effort et pourquoi on
accentuerait l'effort dans le futur
c'est pour des raisons assez simple à on
voit qu'on y arrive de les technologies
coûte de moins en moins chères et tout
le monde le fait et donc il ya un
intérêt à le faire
donc oui il faut à la fois voir si les
contributions qui sont proposés font
déjà faire un changement ça c'est le
premier constat très important et est ce
que ce changement est quand même
significatif
ou est-ce qu'au fond c'est pas très
différent de ce que craignent noko les
climatologues en disant c'est le
business as usual et celui là
aujourd'hui quand on regarde ce qui se
passe ça nommé à quatre degrés nos
premières choses et deuxième chose
comment on relève
l'ambition de cet accord donc c'est ça
le succès de paris
il n'est pas gagnée du succès ce succès
de paris c'est au minimum d'avoir un
mécanisme qui nous permet de revenir de
faire le constat de où on en est de
conserver l'objectif global est de se
donner les états par lequel on va
arriver et ses étapes c'est pas juste
seulement de se revoir tous les cinq ans
pour dire en fait mieux c'est de mettre
en place ce qu'il faut en matière
d'investissement de recherche et
développement sur les technologies
en matière de financement international
pour qu'on y arrive donc sa dépose de
beaucoup des moyens qu'on appelle les
moyens de mise en oeuvre de la de la
convention donc le avoir une chance 50%
de chance au moment où 60% de chances de
lui arriver à ces deux degrés nous ne
pas les dépasser plus tôt c'est quand
même aussi tous ses moyens de mise en
oeuvre qui va falloir éclaircir dans
l'accord de paris voilà vous venez de
suivre l'audition de laurence tubiana
ambassadrice pour les négociations sur
le réchauffement climatique pour la
conférence paris climat 2015 la fameuse
comme 21 la coop 21 un sujet sur lequel
delphine girard revient dans quelques
instants dans votre journal 24 heures
sénat très bonne suite des programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires
oh